PROFESSOR KATHARINA RIBBECK:
My group studies slime.
[LAUGHTER]
[DING]
It is largely viewed as
some sort of waste product,
similar to feces.
And my mission is to, really,
correct this image, and show
that it has really very,
very important functions
for biology.
We focus on mucus.
That is a very important
slime for our body.
Mucus is more commonly
known as snot.
And it coats all wet
everything in our body--
eyes, nose, mouth,
lungs, digestive tract,
and female genital track.
And it has very, very
important functions.
These are bacteria
swimming in slime.
Some of the mucus
can distinguish
between good and bad.
It allows many bacteria
to live in that.
That constitutes our microbiota.
But then it rejects,
in most cases,
bacteria or viruses
that are potentially
harmful to the body.
We have mucus from women
who are in preterm labor,
and women that are
pregnant, at exactly
the same gestational stage.
GRACE YAO: So mayo
is similar to what
mucus in a normal
pregnancy should look like.
It's thick, opaque,
and it doesn't really
form any kind of filament.
It just breaks apart like this.
PROFESSOR KATHARINA RIBBECK:
In preterm pregnancy,
we see that the mucus
may be altered in ways--
that it is more permeable.
[CRACK]
GRACE YAO: Egg white--
so it's more translucent.
And you can see that it
forms a kind of filament when
I stretch my fingers apart.
PROFESSOR KATHARINA RIBBECK:
It really resembles the mucus
as it is during your
fertile phase-- that
is, the maximally
permeable phase, which
is very bad news
because that means
that, potentially, a lot of
pathogens can go through.
One of our goals
with the study is
to look for markers that
might predict, far in advance,
that a woman might be at
risk for preterm labor.
If you grow too fond
of your hypothesis,
and then you do that
one experiment--
which was supposed to be a
control and that proves you
wrong--
then, you can't fall apart.
It's very, very important
to always, always
be prepared that you're wrong.
Discovering mucus-- it's
a roller coaster, really.
Every experiment almost tells
us something new and unexpected.